あのそういう方々ではなくて
あの全く初めて仏教の話を聞く方々のことを頭に入れて
あのお話をさせていただきたいんです
ですから あの どなたでも話の途中でも構いませんから
いつでも疑問やら またわからなかったこととか
あの たまに私もあの言ったつもりで言ってないものも結構ありますから
そのわからなかったら
この流れの中でいつでもそういう話を質問して聞いてください
一応あの このコースの狙いっていうのは
このもう釈尊がお釈迦様があの
おっしゃったことを まあまあいわゆるまあ知識的にいくらかの学問的にまあ紹介したいということで
別にあの宗教的な話ではないんです
ですから あのもう罰が当たるだろうとかね
そういう関係じゃなくて
まあどんどん質問したりしてください
まあまあまあ理解するためのものだから
まあ人間っていうのは誰であろうと自由であるし
考えることも自由であるし
疑うことも自由であるし
質問することも自由ですし
ですから 別にこの まあ私は宗教のものですからといって
あのあまり遠慮したりする必要は全くないんです
あの まあいわゆる宗教の話ではなくて
お釈迦様おっしゃる何をおっしゃったかということは
まあ理解したいということで
まあ話は一応まあお釈迦様は仏教という宗教を教えたんだから
まあ宗教用になりますけど
だからといって何だかんだで迷信で信じる必要ってもなんでもないんです
で あの 今度のこの 5回シリーズのあのメインテーマは
大きなテーマはあのカルマなんですね
それはパーリ語で あのサンスカリット語でも
パーリ語でカンマというんです
サンスクリット語になると
あのカルマというんです
この辞書なんか引いてみると
このこれは上にあるのはお釈迦様が使った言葉
パーリ語なんですね で
これはサンスクリット語なんですけど
あのあまりの根本仏典はサンスクリット語でないんです
サンスクリット語でカルマというんですね
で 日本の大乗仏教ではこのサンスクリット語大変大事に考えてますけど
お釈迦様はサンスクリット語でお話ししたことはないんです
そのその地方の言葉で話しましたから
この人工的な言葉なんで
サンスクリット語っていうのは
それで喋ったことはないんです
ですから サンスクリット語であるお経もほとんどまあ作ったもので
お釈迦様が実際にお話ししたものではありません
ですから まあかなり後になるんですね
お釈迦様が使った言葉の中で一つはパーリ語なんです
また 他の言葉でも喋ったそうなんですが
あの経典残ってないんですね
今残ってるのはパーリ語の経典だけなんですね
で パーリ語でカンマと読んで
サンスクリット語でカルマと読んで
それは辞書を引いてみる
引いてみると出てくる意味は行為なんですね
行為 ACTION ACTIVITY
ですから 英語で言えば
ACTIONですが あるいはACT
行為 なんとか行為 じゃあそうすると業論といえばなんか行為論
行為論というのを喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
で それはそうなんですけど
まあなかなかこの日本語で業ということは
あの なんか日本では人気あるみたいですね
随分人気ある言葉で 業といえば業が深い人がいるんじゃいるんではないかとかね
そういう風に一般的なことわざにも入ってるんですね
その業が深いとかなんとか言うと
この単なるACT行為ということとは随分違うんですね
それからこちらのテーマにも入っているように
いつでも業と因縁って何ですかと話してくると
私も頼んじゃうんですね
頼むたびに私はものすごい怒るんです
業と因縁って何の関係あるんですかと
何の関係もないんで それは仏教の用語をあまりにも知らなすぎなんですね
ですから いつでも業と因縁つなげてもう考えたりするんですね
で これからそういうのはどういうことかと
まあ順番で説明していきます
まず皆様方は知っているところから始まらなくちゃいけない
で 皆様方知ってるっていうのは
この大体日本の文化の中で我々知ってる業と因縁とかね
一般的に使ってる言葉から始まらなくちゃいけないんだけど
だからってお釈迦様の教えをその通りだよというのはちょっとおかしいんですね
そうは決めてないんです
で まあ一般的に我々は業が深いというと
なんかすごい悪い人 悪い運命の運が悪い人のことを考えちゃうんですね
これはなんか因縁でしょうと言ったところで
ああ なんかちょっといいことがあったような感じがするんですね
それは普通の日本の感覚でしょうと思いますね
これ 何かいいことあったら
突然誰かに人に会ったら
これも何とか因縁でしょうと
因縁でしょうと言ったりする
で 何か不幸に出会ったら
なんか業が悪いなとかね
よくもまあ しょっちゅう不幸に出会う人が
まあ業が悪いと なんとか言ったりするような感じがするんですね
それで 一般日本語でいうと
業といえばなんかすごいあってはならないことで
因縁と言えば これはありがたいことになってしまうんですね
まあそれは私はそういうふうに
なんとなく まあ自分が外人ですからね
なんかそんな風に使ってるんではないかというふうな感じがするんです
で 一応結論として言うのは
そういうふうに お釈迦様の教えはその通りでもないということ
いわゆる関係ないと思っちゃえばいいんです
日本ではそう考えてるんだけど
インドに 2500年前に生まれた釈尊考えたことはまた違うんだと
そう覚えておけばわかりやすいと思います
それからこの たまに私に質問する方々のある性格がありまして
あの 自分で何か信じて頑固と信仰しているものはいろんなものあるんですね
それでもそれははっきり明確にわからない
その場合はそれについて聞くんですね
その聞き方が良くないんですね
で それで私には答えられないんですね
で 一番この業やらそういう話が
この日本の有名な経典であるこの法華経とかは
まあいくらか出ているでしょうと思いますけど
そういう方々はよく業の話やら因縁の話やら聞きたくなるんですね
聞く場合は その経典に自分勉強して信仰している経典にあることを説明してくれというような感じになっちゃうんですね
それと 私が聞く感じでは
その話と釈尊の話は違うんではないかと
全く違います それがいきなり答えちゃうんです
それで向こうは反発して
もうあなたは知らないということで
もういつでも物別れになるんです
だから物別れは私はわざとやっちゃうんで
説明してあげないんですね
ある仏教 いくらか勉強した人が私にある日こういう質問をしたんですね
中国の天台智顗は あなた方の仏教はまあ少上仏教ですごいレベルが低いんだと言ってるんだと
自分やっているあのカーストの道が一番レベル高いんだと
それで私に なんであなた方は少女ブックやってるんですかと
どういうわけでと聞くんですね
そんな答えられないですよね
だからあなたは天台寺けど
勝手にやってくださいという感じで
僕はまあそういうふうに返事したんですね
もっと厳しく 天台寺がそう決めたんだから
私はそれは説明しなくちゃいけない
そういうふうに質問すると
自分で何か固定概念があって答えられないんですね
例えば もっとわかりやすい例でいうとわかるんですね
例えば ある日本の方が
私は世界一美しいのは美しい人々は日本人だと思っている
他の人間はみんな醜いだと思っている
それであなたはそんな醜く生まれて気持ちいいんですか？とその人に聞いたら
どう答えればいいんですかね
そうするとおかしいでしょうに
自分がそう思ったんだから
そうなる必要はないんですね
ですから この我々知識人がそういうふうに初めから決めつけて
私が考えることは正しいんだ
人は考えることは間違ってるんだと思ってから
あんたよくも間違ってる考え方を持ってるんですねと
その人を批判したっても
ただ言ってる人がバカになるだけなんですね
そうじゃなくて 私はこういうふうに考えている
あなたはどのように考えているんでしょうかと
と聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで互いに話し合うと
そこで相手方は まあ私はあなたの考え方はこういうこういうポイントから見ると違いますと思いますよと
向こう側もあなたの考え方も
こうこうやるふうに見ると違いますよと
というふうに話し合ったらいいんですね
喧嘩する必要はないんです
ですから 一応頭を綺麗にして聞いていただきたいんです
ですから 私がもうバンバン言いたい放題のことを勝手に言いますけど
一応もう仮にでもこちらで教師ですから
だからって皆様方は必ずしももう聞く相手になる必要はないんです
何か反論があったら どんともう反論してください
で 反論するのは自由ですけど
この反論自体が私の話の内容に直接関係ある時だけ答えるんです
関係ないんだったら 話他の世界に行っちゃうんだったら
まあ時間の関係で まあ一応あの
後回しにするしか方法ないんです
ですから 質問がもし直接私の話の内容に関係あるとすぐ答えるんです
それでまあ戻ります 辞書を引くと
カルマ カルマ カルマというのはACT
あるいは行為 それだったら行為だから
そんなにきめ細かく勉強したりする必要はないんです
でも インドの世界で インドの宗教の世界で
そのもう一つ意味があったんです
その意味がなぜ出たかというと
意味後に説明しますけど
何かACT 行為をしたら必ずしも結果が出るんですね
私は今ある行為をしているんです
喋るという行為 でっかい声で
それで結果として皆様の耳が痛いと
という結果があるんですね
私はすごく日本語いろいろ間違ったりすると
そうすると ちゃんと日本語で考える皆様は
なんとなく心の中でなんだろうとかね
ちょっと気持ち悪くなったりはする
それ私もあります あの人が英語なんか喋ってると間違っちゃうと
別に人を非難しているわけじゃなくて
言ってる言葉自体文法なんか間違っちゃうと
なんかちょっと何だろうというふうに感じになっちゃうんですからね
ですから私は日本語を喋るという行為をしている
そちらの結果があるんですね
皆様の耳が痛いとかね
あるいはうるさかったとか
なんとか結果が必ず出てくるんです
そこで私にも何か結果があるんですね
私はずっと喋ってるんだから
その行為の結果として疲れると
例えば人が走るという行為をする
走るという行為をしたなら
結果として疲れたという結果が出てくるんですね
人はご飯食べるという行為をする
それで結果として満腹しました
楽しかったという結果が得られる
そこで皆様方はこそこそと人の悪口隠れて言うと
それは一つの行為なんですね
その喋ったことはその本人にバレたと
そうするとそちらの結果として大変な結果が得られるんですね
その人と仲が悪くなったとか
喧嘩になったとかね あるいはなんとか結果が出てくるんです
世の中のそういうふうな
この何か行為があったら
必ず 必ずかないかわかりませんだけど
一応結果が出るんです
それでもっと明確に見ると
どんな行為にも何らかの結果があるはずなんです
結果がなしに行為が起こるわけじゃないんです
それはこの物理学で言ってるんですね Every
action has its own reactionという
あの どんなアクション
行為にも その場合は物理学的な行動なんですけど
リアクションもありますと
で まあニュートンさんですか
彼が言ってる法則の一つですから
皆様私より知ってるだろうと思いますけどね
で 日本語でどう言うか
ちょっと覚えてないんですけど
ですから あの どんな行為にも何かの結果がある
それで行為に結果があるということ
一応難しくないんだからね
当たり前のことだから覚えておきましょう
それは一般的なこと 走ったら疲れると
で まあそんな感じのご飯食べたら満腹になるとかね
そういう風に結果があるんだと
ご飯食べても食べても満腹にならないということにはならないんですね
満腹にはなりますから
確実に そういうふうに行為に結果がある
それでインドの世界 当時のインドの世界では
まあそれはまあ 一般的には誰でも知ってることだからね
行為と結果ということは認めていたんだけど
さらにこの なんか人間の運命やら宿命やら
で そういうところにもその話を持っていったんですね
例えば人を見ると 人は不幸だと
不幸っていうのは結果にすると
その人は何か不幸になる行為をしておかなくちゃいけない
そこでその人の人生を見たら
何か悪いことをしたんですかって別に見つからない
でも不幸だ ああ それだったら
これはその人の運命だと
じゃあ運命というならば
今世で悪いことを何もしていないんだから
おそらく過去生で悪いことをしたんではないかと
まあ推測するんですね
わかりますか？その簡単な論理なんです
普通だったら まあ人が痩せてるんだったら
あまり食べてないということは見えてくるし
あの人は随分痩せて もう体あまり成長していないなと見たら
ああ あまり栄養は取ってないと探してみればすぐ見つかるんです
でも なんか人が不幸で
何やっても成功しないとか
どこへ行ってもトラブルを起こすとかいろいろあると
そうするとこの人は不幸ばっかしで
不幸になるならば何か悪いことでもしておかないと不幸にならないと
でも人生 その人の生き方やら考えてみると
別に悪いことしてるわけじゃないんだと
結構正直な人間だと それでもこの人なぜ不幸かというと
あ これだったらこの人
過去生ででも悪いことをしたんではないかというふうに考えちゃうんですね
そういうのはほとんど推測で考えちゃうんですね
別に体験したわけじゃないんです
[背景音楽]それで行為の結果はまあちょっと時間延びちゃったんですね
例えば私は強くこの机ぶっ殴ったら
その場でその瞬間で手が痛いんです
その場で その なんで人が不幸ですかというのは
それを過去生の行為というと
その場ではないんですね
なんか結果に結果起こる時間が随分延びちゃったんです
ということは 私は今机ぶん殴ったら明後日手が痛くなるというふうな感じになっちゃうんですね
でもそれも考えてみると嘘じゃないんです
例えば まあ何かこの事故を起こしちゃったと
骨が折ったり腰が折ったり
いろんなことになったと
そこで病院に運ばれて
それなりに治療してリハビリして帰ると
でもどんどん筋肉が衰えてきて
年取ってくると あの十年前の事故の影響であっちこっち痛くなったり
ふうなことがあるでしょう
すぐその場で結果が出なくても
十年経ってから結果が出るということもあります
ですから 行為にすぐ結果が出なくても
別にそれは不思議ではないんですね
まあ後で時間経ってから
何年間経ってからも出られるんですね
それ見ると 人の行為の結果は必ずしも今世で今すぐなくても
二十年後  四十年後でも怒られるし
四十年後でも怒られるならば
なんで三年後で怒られないんでしょうかね
ですから 三年後でも一年後でも怒られると
そういう風に理屈作られるんでしょう
その論理によって違う業論がインドでできたんですね
その違う業論は我々言ってる
日本でも言ってる この宿命
運命というふうな方向へ行ってしまったんですね
その違う業論というのは
あの 特に人の運命についてのものなんですね
それは普通の言葉で言えば
人が悪いことをしたら必ずいつか悪い結果になるんだと
いいことをしたならば
必ずいつかいい結果になるんだと
このいつかというポイント
大事なんですね すぐその場ではないんです
だから いつでしょうかっていうことはわからないんですね
じゃあ今日このテーマで皆様聞きたがってるのはその業論なんです
普通のあの行為論ではないんです
でお釈迦様はこの行為論
業論というのはもうあまり区別しないで一緒にまとめて置いておくんですね
同じ法則だと 机強くぶったらその場で痛い
もし骨 骨に割れ目も入ったら
まあ 一ヶ月間経つまで痛いと
ちゃんと治療しなかったならば
まあ一生指が変になっちゃうというふうに
このことだから あの まあお釈迦様は大体あの両方もう一緒にしているんですね
行為も運命も宿命も定めもなんだかんだも一緒に考えてみましょうということで
それでこのインドの宗教家たちが
まあお釈迦様の当時の
またお釈迦様以前の宗教
宗教の方々はまあいろんなことをおっしゃってて
一部だけは紹介します
で ある人々がこう言ってたんです
人々のすべてのことは全部全体的に過去で決まられているんだと
いわゆる今の私の人生は全部すべて過去の行為の結果だと
過去っていうのは過去生ですね
生まれる以前の行為の結果ですよと
それは日本語で言えば
この絶対的行為論 カルマ論
業論と言っても構いません
で まあそれはそれなりに理由があるんだけどね
で もし我々のね まあ全部過去の過去やったことの結果でしたらで
まあ何でも我々やってること
結果が必ず出るんだから
今やってることは全部何かの結果ですから
じゃあそれは全部過去の結果でしょうと決めちゃったんです
そういう考え方は お釈迦様は仏教では認めてないんです
認めてない理由はこういう理由なんです
過去の結果だからもう決まってるんですね
過去だから 一旦やったものはもう終わったんだから
それはもうどうしようもない
変化することも何もできません
過去だから そうすると
我々の人生にはもうどうすることもできなくなっちゃう
決まってる通りにプログラムされてる通りに生きるしかないんです
例えば 明日私の目が一つなくなる予定だったら
それはどうしてももう避けることはできない
そういう風に決まってるならばということで
で そうすると まあ大変なことになりますけどね
で お釈迦様はまあもっと具体的に物事を考えて
それを否定するんですね
でも人間が本当にそうですかと
我々は引いてる線路にずっと動くだけですかと
その線路をちょっとポイントで他の方向へ持っていくことはできないんですかと
我々完全に全て決まられているんですか
と言うと まあそうではないと
人間には自分の意志というものがありまして
人間にそれなりに自分の気持ち次第で幸福になるかならないか
もういろいろ方向を変えることは可能じゃないかと
そういうことで それは仏教で否定しているんですね
全て前もって決まってるんだということも否定している
それから もう一人の哲学者たちがもっと違うことを言ってたんです
もう全部偶然だと いわゆるこの行為に結果がないと言ってるわけじゃなくて
まあ偶然だと 前もって定めているわけじゃないんだと
私は外を出たところで
まあ人に殴られて死んじゃったと
それはまあ偶然にその人に会ったんだから
殴られて死んだんであって
それ以上何の意味もないんだと
突然 偶然 だから偶然という人々もカルマ論を否定しているわけじゃなくて
それはまあすぐその場で出る結果であって
あのもう時間は長く延びちゃったでしょ
そういうことじゃないんだと
あるいは殺されるべきにして殺されたわけじゃなくて
たまたま偶然で殺されたんだと
で まあ悪いことだけじゃなくて
例えばいいことでも同じことなんですね
まあ大変私にとって大変もう必要な幸福なある人に出会ったと
で その場合もそれはまあ偶然だと
それはどういうことかというと
それも人間に考えれば
まあそれもそうでしょうと言えないわけでもないんですね
全部偶然だよと それも仏教で否定するんですね
すべて偶然でもないんだと
なぜ否定するんでしょうかね
すべて偶然だと言ったら
また人間にどうすることもできなくなっちゃうんですね
勉強してよく頭が良くなったっても
それはまた偶然で勉強しないで頭が悪くなる
それまた偶然でとかね
何でも偶然だから幸福が出てくるまで待つしかないんです
そういうことで まあ偶然ということも仏教では認めないんです
それは間違っているんだと
まあこういう論間違っているというんじゃなくて
すべての我々得る結果が全く偶然だよということもよくないと
まだそれほどはっきりわからないかもしれませんけど
もう一つの教えがありまして
この何も関係ないんだと
人間は全く自由に生きているんだと
他の過去のこととか何とかとか
何の関係もないんだと
ただその時その時それなりに生きれるんだと
お金がたくさんあったら大変美味しい食べ物を食べたりするし
お金がなかったらそんなに美味しくないものは買って食べたりするとかね
お金がたくさんあったら外国旅行までするんだと
そんなたくさんのお金がなければ
そこら辺散歩だけして終わっちゃうとかね
それに他の何の意味もないんだと
いわゆるノンレレベントということで
全く我々は何の影響もなしに
完全に自由に生きているんだと
で それをお釈迦様の教えではもうそれも認めないんですね
人間 完全たる自由でもないんですね
いろんなことによって支配されていることはみんなわかっているんです
もう一人のそういう哲学の宗教家の名前は今日言いませんけど
ちゃんといろいろ経典に記録しているんですね
そういう人々はそういうふうな教えを言っていたんだと
もう一人のグループが
この人間やること 何だかんだももう確実にすべては行為としてこの結果が得られるように
このカルマになってしまうんだと
業になってしまうんだと
という 徹底的にカルマを業を教える人々もいましたし
それもあまり仏教で認めてない
ちょっとそこら辺ちょっと難しいんですから
やめます それで問題は
じゃあお釈迦様 業ということはどのように教えたかということですね
それでまたもう一回 業の理解の方に戻ってみましょう
何が業か 何がカルマかと
それはなんで我々はそんなことを考えるかというと
私たちには例えばよく真面目に仕事をすると
それなりに幸福になる
それは理解できる すごく健康な食べ物を食べて
適当な運動をして生活すると
もう体力があって健康な体で長生きできる
それもよくわかります
よく真面目に勉強すると遊ばないで結構勉強できるようになってしまう
それから もし病気になって重い病気になって
体にいろいろ故障症とかいろんなものを残ったと
それから歩けなくなったとか
でもいくらかは分かりますね
どういう意味かと で 世の中でだいたい私たちに
例えば世界的な経済の今
回転があまり良くないんだから
日本の経済の回転も良くないんだとと分かるんですね
そういう分かることについて
人間があんまり不思議には考えないんですね
で ものすごい不思議ですよと
今の経済状態悪いっていうのは
これえらい不思議なことだよとか
誰も考えない 大体どういうわけでそうなっていたかっていうことはわかってますから
でもたまたま我々になんだろうとわからないこともあるんですね
なんでそうなったんですかと
例えば すごく正直に 真面目に
真剣に仕事はしているんだけど
会社側からものすごくそれを嫌がれるんだと
とにかくリストラにしようと
そればっかり会社の方が考えてないんだと
で 後で追い出されたんだと
そこで会社に勤まってる人々はほとんど真面目に仕事をしないんだと
そういうこともあるんですね
そこでクビになった人が
私は本当に真面目に仕事をしたのに
あの私はクビになって
あの全然真面目に仕事をしないでもいい加減にやっていた人々はもう残っているんではないかと
どういうことかと あるいはすごく自分言うことよく聞いて
真剣真面目に勉強していた自分の子供がいるんだと
それでなんかある日突然
もう勉強もしないし 言うことも聞かない
もう暴力ふるようになってしまったと
なんで急にこうなったんですかと
学校にずっと行っていた子供が急に学校に行きたくないんだと
学校に行こうと言うんだったら自殺するんだと
親を脅かしたり脅したりするし
親も怖くなって もう学校に行きなさいと言わなくなっちゃうし
でもなんでこの子供はこうなったんでしょうかと
という理由わからなくなっちゃうんですね
そういう我々に なんでそうなっただろうかとわからない時
その言葉頭に出てくるんですね
これはもうなんで 運命ではないかと
なんとか業ではないかと
というふうに人が考えたりする
ですから 業論に大体入るのは
そういうはっきりと理由はわからないものだけなんです
仏教も同じなんです 人間の知識で原因わかるものは別に業論で扱わなくても
そこら辺はわかります
それも業は業なんですけど
真っ直ぐに仕事をする人は真っ直ぐに成功して幸福になるということも業なんですけど
でも原因わかってるんだから
不思議ではないんですね
この運命 宿命 定めという言葉で言ってる人の運命についてのことを喋ることが
業として扱っているんですね
じゃあその業論についてなんですけど
じゃあ喋るよと思ったところで大変なことになっちゃうんです
お釈迦様がこういうことをおっしゃっているんです
人間が考えてはあかんこと四つあるんです
考えてはいけませんと
理解できないんだと ただ頭が狂ってしまうんだと
あまりにも考えられないことをやっちゃいますから
その中の四つの中の一つは業のこと
考えて理解しようと思わない方がいいんだと
それぐらい人間の頭では考えられないんだと
複雑ですよと もう一つ
四つありますから 一つはこの宇宙のこと
それはいくら考えたってももうやりきれないんです
あまりにも大きくて膨大で
宇宙の時間見てももう何万単位で計算すればいいんですかね
一つの星が現れて死ぬまでどれぐらい時間経つでしょうかね
我々の寿命はどれぐらいですかね
そんなこと考えたっても考えきれないんですね
それで宇宙のようなことを考えたとするならば
だから何ですかと 例えば宇宙の遠いどこかどこかで新しい星が生まれてるんだと
誰が発見する？だから何かあるの？それで
何の意味もないんですね
今どこかの星団で どこかのところで星がもう死んでるんだと
まあ知ったって ああ すごい面白い
それだけで終わっちゃうんですね
我々にとっちゃ別にその何の関係もないし
ただ面白いということだけで終わっちゃうんですね
今あなた見ている星が本当は 二億年前で死んでるものだよと
別にだから何ですかね
別に何のこともないんです
そういうことで そういうことを考えたっても
人間にはもうほとんど役に立たない
それ二番目 三番目は心の法則なんですね
心はどのように働いて
どのように我々に影響を与えているかっていうことも
人間には考えきれないものなんです
いくら考えても それも放っといた方がいいと
必要なものは心の法則をお釈迦様がおっしゃっているし
重要なとこだけ それ以上考える必要ないと
で 次に悟ったならば ブッダになったならば
あれどういう人かと どんな心を持ってるんでしょうかとかね
それは絶対人間には考えられないこと
その四つを考えても考えきれないと
考えちゃったらただ狂ってしまうだけですよと
頭混乱して混乱だらけで終わるだけですよと
そういうことで 今日のテーマは本当は仏教ではもう喋ってはいけないテーマなんです
だから公開演でやめるしかないんです
で なんでそんなテーマ出来上がっちゃうかというと
これ私は大乗仏教のせいだと思いますけどね
大乗仏教はお釈迦様は簡単単純で
どんな人間にも どんな時代で
どんな科学発展したっても
誰にでも理解できるすごい科学的な教えを教えたのに
それを見ようと実践しようと考えようとしないで
お釈迦様言わなかったことを探すんですね
僕は昔勉強するときはこの華厳という教えがありますね
それは私は華厳とは聞いたことがないんだけど
私は聞いたのはアヴァタンシャカという言葉なんですけど
この日本に来てから それは日本語で華厳と言うんだよと
漢字はわかりませんだけど
華厳の で という宗派があるんです
大乗仏教なんですけど
で 私は遠い昔 勉強していた時は
この最初に言われたことは
この華厳で教えているのは
釈迦尊が一言葉もしゃべらなかった教えですよと
言葉で言ったのは何か違う教えで
全然言葉で全く言わなかった教えがあるんだと
それは華厳だと と言って
まあいろんな宇宙のことやら
まあよく喋るんです 大日如来さんのことやらね
まあいろんなこと そこで私はガキでしたから
その時は すぐ頭に入ったのは
お釈迦様はまるっきりもう全くも人に間接的にも暗示してはなかったものは
あんた方はどうやって知ってるんですかと
知るはずないでしょうと
なぜならば お釈迦様は間接的にでも暗示したことでもない教えは阿頼耶識だから
だからはっきりと言うと
釈迦尊の教えでないというふうな結論に出るだけではないかと
ですから 言わなかったことを研究しようと思ったら
なんかバカバカらしいんでしょうね
言ったことを研究するのは正しいでしょうね
ということは お釈迦様は言わなかったことを研究しようとすると
世界中あるとあらゆる何を研究したっても同じことなの
どうやって大泥棒になるかどうかね
どんな風にバレないように銀行強盗できるかとか研究したっても
それも仏教になっちゃうんです
阿頼耶識宗教になっちゃうんです
なぜならば そんなことお釈迦様おっしゃってないんだからと
だからそういうのはすごく
この  それは私のガキ頃のもう反論でしたからね
あまりあまり考えなくたってもいいんだけど
おかしいと思ったんですね
勉強しながら 内容を見たら
またどうせおかしいことでしたけど
まあとにかくそういうふうに
このお釈迦様はこの立ち触る必要ないっていうとこは
まあどんどん扱って もう考えたりする
お釈迦様は全然答えられない
答えませんという質問がいろいろあったんですね
それに答えなかったのは
それなりのわけがあったんです
それにまた答えようとする
だから ある哲学 宗教を作った
作った人が置いたものが
弟子たちにそれ扱うということは
まあ普通だったら不可能なんですけど
それを言ったのは この
一応仏教ではあんまりそんなに真剣真面目に人の運命は何でしょうかとかね
は考えないんです そんなに真剣なこの初期仏教ではね
そんなに真剣真面目に人間人間の運命はこうなります
ああなりますとはないんです
まあそこそこに お釈迦様がおっしゃったところだけ
役に立つところだけ まあ理解して
それで終わっちゃうんです
厳密な分析はできない
で そこでこのカルマ 業ということに何が入るかというと
また戻りますけど 我々に科学的に合理的に理解できるところは入らないんですね
今説明しましたね 例えば
真面目に仕事をすれば
それなりに収入があって幸福になりますというぐらいのことは
合論に別に入らないんですね
なんで仕事を真剣にやってるのに
あまりお金が入らないかと
お金が入るんだけど なんで全部すぐ消えてしまいますかとかね
なんでいつでも自分の家族で病気
病人ばっかしですかとかね
その時なんですね みんな考えちゃうのは
その時世の中の人々は何を言うんですかと
大体日本みたいな仏教文化ある社会では
まあおそらくそれあなたの業でしょうと
あなたの業でしょうと言っちゃうんですね
あんた不幸になってる
例えば子供が欲しくて欲しくてたまらないんだけど
なかなか子供が生まれてこないと
まあそれもあなたの過去の業かもしれませんとかね
恵まれてないかもしれませんとかね
それで 恵まれているか
恵まれていないかというポイントが
カルマの分野で扱うんです
それから あの 大体みんな好きなことありますね
占い 占ってもらうと 人相占いとか
手相占いとかありますね
ああいうのは全然科学とは全く縁もない
合理的な世界と全く関係ないことなんです
あんたは何年何月何日何曜日も何時間で生まれたんだから
あんたはこういうこういう人だよと
だから何年何月何日何曜日も何時間で生まれたんだからといって
こういう風になる必要ないでしょうに
でもやっぱりそうなりますよという風に言っちゃう
星占いとかではね そういうことも合理的な世界から離れているんだから
まあカルマ論にでは扱えるんです
で またこの まあ我々なんで不幸になるかというと
また他の何言うんでしょうかね
あ それから戦争の怨念とかね
なんとかの霊の祟りではないかとかね
なんとか探しちゃうんです
言い訳みたいなものがね
そういう世界全部まとめて
まあ合論にしちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと思います
ですから まあ今から星占いはどんな働きかとか説明しなくちゃいけないんだけど
大体なんで人が星占いしてもらいますかというと
普通の常識でなんか分からないんですね
だから占ってもらおうとする
大体若い女の人々が誰か相手が欲しいんですね
お友達が なかなか自分が一生懸命おしゃれしているはずなんですけど
なかなか誰ももう言葉かけてくれないと
それで あの どこかの占いの館に行って
まあ占ってもらうと で
そちらの方々は じゃああと三ヶ月間で
あなたにはまあぴったし合う人がある人に恵まれますよ
ああそうですか よかったと
そこでまあ ですから我々占いなどに行くのは理由はわからないんだからなんです
病弱になっていると理由わかるんだったら占い師の方に行かないんだけど
わからないと行っちゃうんですね
それから なんで神社仏閣やらいろんなところに行ったり
お祓いしてもらったりとかね
いろんなそういう神秘的なこと
迷信的なこと あるいは宗教的なことをするんですかというと
それも業の世界で もうなんとか幸福になりたいんだけど
まあ理由わからない とにかく神様にお願いしていましょうと
そちらにも入っているのは業の世界なんですね
まあそういうわけで 人間にとっては大変この聞きたい気持ちは分かりますけどね
知りたい気持ちは わかるんだけど
仏教ではそんなことを考えたりすると
電車が遅れるよと 何も知らないうちに早く死んでしまっちゃうんです
短い人生でつかまる幸福もつかまれませんと
ということで 例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想とか瞑想実践もやってますからね
そういう方々にとってはもう全然気にしない方がいい話なんです
そこであのお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
この何でもこのある いつでも証拠
実証 自分で自ら確かめてみる教えを教えているんですね
ですから このすごい科学よりこの科学性を持ってるんですね
信仰やら信じることにはそれほど力がないんです
脅すことを全くしない
もう言うことはきちんと合理的にもう理解してくださいと
それから確かめてみてくださいと
理解することは確かめることではないんです
2つですからね ですから
その方法で言ってるんですね
ですから この だいたい私の言葉で言えば
もう科学しちゃうんですね
ですから 釈尊の教えから申し上げるならば
五を五論を我々はこれから科学しなくちゃいけないんです
それはできない 全部できないんだけど
できる お釈迦様がおっしゃった部分だけ
まあこれから順番であの科学してみます
正しい知恵に正しい考え方に仏教で使っている言葉がありまして
正見というんですね 見というのは見るという感じで
正というのは正しい 正しい智慧に正見というんです
間違っているものには
間違っているのが邪見というんですけどね
人間の知恵 知識っていうのは正しくなければいけません
それは当たり前のこと
間違っていることを誤解しちゃったら
決していい結果は得られない
そういうことで 我々の知識と知恵がとことん正しくするために
間違っているものは全部直して
しっかりと知恵と知識が生まれるように
お釈迦様は説法したんですね
ですから この説法っていうのは聞きにくいとかね
いろいろありますよ なんか聞いてると
なんかすごくもうなんかきついことを言ってるんではないかとかね
そんなことは聞きたくないとかね
そういうものに そのままお釈迦様はおっしゃるんですね
私はそんな話聞きたくないと言ったっても
それは聞かなくちゃいけないんだったらどうしようもないでしょうね
それでどんどん言っちゃうんです
ですから 人間に必ずも正しい知識と正しい智慧必要なんです
それで正しい智慧の正見の一部がこの業論を認めること
それはパーリ語でこう書くんです
ちょっと長いんだけど
えーと こういう風に書きますけど
読み方はカムマッサカタ・サッマディッティ
カムマッサカタ・サッマディッティ
この大体母音の上でたまたまこうやってこの線を引いたりはします
この線を引いたりするのは
そこの母音は伸ばすんです
ですから カムマッサカタ・サッマディッティ
まあカタカナにしちゃったらなんか変な発音になりますからね
まあそのまま読めば結構ですけど
この T の下に点二つ入れてるんですね
それはこの普通の英語の T の発音と違って
もうちょっと強く発音するんです
ディッティと ディッティではなくて
ディッティと ディッティ
そこは そこはどうでもいいんです
[笑い]ですから 業論を理解することも正見なんです
正しい智慧なんです と言いながら
お釈迦様それ考えるなと言ってるんだからどうしましょうかね
矛盾じゃないんですかね
で まぁ矛盾にはならないんです
人間知りたがることはおかしいんです
例えば この星占い信じている人々が
これぴったし当たりますねとか言うんです
それから なんでそんなにぴったし当たるんでしょうかと自分で考えちゃうんです
見つかるんですかね 見つからないんです
宇宙の空の上でどこかどうか星があるんだからといって
それ計算して あの西洋
あの星占いもインドの星占いも同じことをやってるんですね
一生懸命計算しちゃうんですね
星がどんなところにどのようにあるかと
中国になっちゃうと またこの
まぁなんとかまぁ方位学やらなんか水なんとかっていうね
え？なんとかいろいろ学問がありますけどね
それでぴったし合いますよ
中国の方々は言うんですね
それからなんで合いますかと考えちゃうと見つかるんですかね
見つからないでしょうに
ですから そういう風に考える必要はないということなんです
考えたって で そういう
まぁ仏教で星占い全く扱ってないんですけど
一応考えちゃったら狂っちゃいますけど
じゃあどうやって正見作りますかと
カルマについては それでお釈迦様は人間に必要な関係ある
知らねばならないところは教えているんですね
それは理解することなんですね
でもまたお釈迦様 また逆にずるいんです
またすごい知識的にも喋ったりするんです
この言葉 でもこれから私は分析して説明します
もうカムマっていうのは行為ですね
カムマっていうのは行為
こちらの S 一つは余分に割り込むんです
次の言葉はサカという言葉なんです
この言葉  S A K A サカ
サカというのは自分という意味なんですね
英語で言えばセルフという意味で
これで日本語では分析
まあ説明できませんですけど
ドイツ語と同じく次の言葉はタなんです
タっていうのは それは名詞にするんです
これ女性名詞で 行為は自分のものであることを理解しましょうということなんです
サマーディとは正見 それで合理的に言えばどういうことかというと
自分がやったことは自分に返ってくるということなんです
それぐらい理解しておけばよくないんだと
もし私が まあ悪い例は一番わかりやすいんだから言いますけど
私はまあ人を殺してしまっちゃうんだと
それで罰受けるのは誰ですか？それやった私でしょうに
その代わりにインドの誰か捕まって
その人を裁判にかけるってことは全くないんです
自分がやることは自分に返ってくる
それはだいたい理解できますね
自分が勉強したら弟の頭が良くなったというケースがあります？そういうことはないでしょうに
自分が勉強すると それで自分の頭が良くなったと
で たまに怠けの学生たちいるんですね
人を勉強するまで待っていて
それをそのままカニングして
自分も頭が良くなったようにしようかと
そういうふうなことで頭良くなるわけじゃないんです
ですから 自分の行為の結果が自分に戻ってくるんだとというぐらいの理解は正見というんです
それで十分です それでまあもうちょっとレベル低い話にしますけど
あの怠けの人々はそれを悪く考えちゃうんですね
で 例えば奥さんが一生懸命いろんないいことをしているんだと
社会福祉したり 人を助けたり
いろんなことをしてるんだと
旦那さんがまるっきり無関心だと
そこであ あいつやってるんだから
私はやらなくてもいいやと
と思っちゃうんです あいつは一生懸命やってるんだから
それでいいんじゃないかと
でも 自分には戻ってこないんです
旦那さんが亡くなったら
旦那さんのやったことによってその結果が得られる
奥さんがやったことは奥さんがやったことで
その結果が得られる あるいは同じ
逆に旦那さんがいいことをするんだからといって
奥様が良くなるということは全くあってないんです
結婚とは関係ないんです
ですから 亡くなったところで
あの何 閻魔様[笑い]
閻魔様のところに離婚証明書を 離婚じゃなくて結婚証明書を持って行っても
じゃああなたにも半分というようにならないんです
財産の半分は奥さんもらいますけど
こうカルマの半分はもらえません
それで覚えてほしいのは
この日本でちょっとしたおかしい考え方があるんですね
ある家庭で 例えば誰かが悪いことをしちゃったら
その家庭丸ごとに否定しちゃうんですね
あるいは仏教から見れば邪見であって
ある兄弟の中で一人が犯罪を起こしましたと
その人が犯罪を起こしたんであって
親にそれは関係ないんです
他の兄弟にもそれ関係ないんです
それみんな別々なんです
ですから あの家族はまあああいうことをやった家族だといって
家族丸ごとに家族も まあまあ孫まで否定するというのは
もうもう完全に邪見であって
上の子が悪いことしたって
もう下の子も必ずしも同じということは全くないんです
ほとんどやるのは反対のことなんです
上の兄弟 上の人がずいぶん悪いことをしちゃうと
見てください 下の子は全くその反対にすっごい立派に活動するんです
例えば 両親が全く勉強やら知識やら無関心になっちゃうと見てください
子供たちは必死になって勉強しちゃうんです
ですから 両親の頭が悪いんだからといって
勉強したことがないんだから
学歴がないんだからといって
子供もそうですよということはありえないんです
みんな別々 個人個人 自分がやることの結果
自分に返ってくる そういうのは仏教的な考え方
ですから まあこの個人主義
それは大事にしなくちゃいけない
母親が一生懸命いいことをするんだからといって
まあ子供たちが悪いことをしていると
悪い結果がいるだけであって
そういう考え方にカッマッサカタサンマディティというんだよ
カッマは自分のものであると
業は自分だけのものであると
覚えておいてください
そうすると 結構人間の社会関係はうまくいっちゃうんです
これは親のせいだと平気で言う人々いるでしょうね
自分の不幸が せっかく育ててくれたのに
それは自分のせいでしょうね
で 言うんです そのカウンセリングの場合でもね
親は厳しく育てた 育てられたんだからと思いますよとか
自分はすごく自信がないんだと
ある人 私に直接言ったんです
自分にはもう何したって全く自信がないんだと
すぐもう落ち込んでしまっちゃうんだと
人と喋る力もないんだと
で 私はもうあんたはそれなぜでしょうかと思いますかと聞いたら
父親がずいぶん厳しかったんだと
だからだと思いますよと
僕はすぐ怒ったんです
いい加減にしろと こんなに大人になって
いまだにあなたを父親
あなたを厳しく何か言ってるんですかと
あれやれ これやれとか
それはあなたでしょうと
父親のせいにするなと
父親は精一杯やったんだと
いい子に育てようと だから厳しくしたでしょうと
それを悪く受け取ったのはあなたでしょうと
お父さんが一生懸命心配して
遊ぶと叱るわ 勉強しないと叱るわとか
悪いことしたったらものすごい厳しく叱っちゃうとかね
それは父親の精一杯のいい行為であって
だから世の中人間にも顔を合わせて逃げ回っているのは
その本人の問題でありますから
そういう風にこの人間が何でも他人ね
他人のせいにする癖があるんですね
我々の幸福も不幸も何でも
ですから このカッマッサカタサンマディティという
この行為は自分のものであるという智慧
そういう問題に答えちゃうんです
あなたのものだよと 結果はあなたがやったことの結果だよと
社会のせいだ 家族のせいだ
会社のせいだとかね 親の育ち方がとかね
って言うんじゃないんです
自分の受け止め方なんですね
親は厳しく育てると結構立派に立派な社会人になる人々いるでしょうに
その数が多いでしょうに
しっかりとしつけをつけて
ちゃんと勉強させた厳しい家庭で育てられた人々を統計取ってみたら
成功している方が多いんです
失敗する人いうことほとんど少ないしね
ですから それはその子供の受け止め方なんです
嫌だと受け止めだったら
もう全部人生全部嫌になってしまっちゃうし
やっぱり親が怖いんだからしっかりしなくちゃと思った人が
人生をずっとしっかりするんです
だから結局自分の行為なんです
会社で叱られたら もう仕事をする自信なくなったというのは上司のせいじゃないんです
しっかりもうものすごく厳しく叱られたんだからだったら
やっぱりしっかりせねばならないんだと
二度と叱られないようにしなくちゃと決めたら
その人は別に問題は作らないし
ああ 嫌だと この上司では嫌だと思ったら
その人はその会社は失敗するし
仕事も ですから このできるだけのこと
他人のせいにしない方がいいんです
できるだけ できればまあ責任だと思った方が正しいんですけどね
まあそうでもない時もありますしね
例えばこの間 随分雪が降ったんですね
まあそれでも私も寒かったんだからね
それは私の責任だとしても
よく降ったんだから みんな寒かったしね
ですから まあそういうとこもあるし
それで電車が止まっちゃったらみんな困っちゃうし
で 行きたいところに行けないし
行きたいところに行きたいとき
そんな約束守れなかったら
あなたのせいだと言ったっても
それはもう自分ではどうすることもできないんだからね
大体そういうのは問題にならないでしょうにね
大体そんな問題にならないんです
社会のことは ですから
結局私たちの幸福も不幸も
私たちの行為の結果だよと理解することは
仏教のまあ正しい智慧と言うんですね
正しい知識と言うんです
で きめ細かく証明を探さなくてもいいんです
なぜならば 今現在 我々の生き方で我々わかってるんだから
で 私は日本でものすごい長い
嫌になるほど長い時間いたんだけど
いまだに立派な日本語を喋れませんし
それは誰のせいかというと
私のせいなんですね ちょっと喋るようになったところで
ああ もうできた もうそれで十分だと
もう終わって決めて決めつけて終わっちゃったんですね
それから一言も勉強しようとしない
自分の言葉直そうともしない
だからそのまんまで成長しない
それは誰のせいでもなく
あくまでも私自身のせいなんですね
で ずっと私が あの で 私は日本に来てから
もう何年経ってから生まれた子供たちが立派に日本語喋ったりするわ
漢字書けるわ 試験受けるわ
その子供たちより先に日本に先から日本にいる私は未だに下手なんです
で たまたまそういうことにあってね
ある すごい雨が降ってる時
この私は傘持っていたんだから
女の子二人がいきなり傘の中に入っちゃったんですね
駅まで行かなくちゃと
まあどうぞどうぞって入れてあげたんだけど
行ったらまあそのまあほんの三分ぐらい歩いたんだけど
その間でまあその二人がものすごい女の子たちだからよく喋るんですね
で 喋ると僕は急にあ この人々は私は私の年はわかってないんだと
なんか同じ仲間としてもう喋ってるんですね
あんた日本語よく喋るんですねとか
日本でもう何年いるんですか？と聞いたら
僕はね まあもしかするとあなた方は生まれた時でしょうね
で その時自分が恥ずかしくなったんですね
本当は あの まあ若い女の子二人でしたけど
まあ高校生ぐらいか もうそこまでないか分からないんだけどね
すごい元気で もう日本語喋るわね
いろいろ試験受ける その子供たち
私は日本に来た年 それで聞いたら
やっぱり私は次の年生まれたんだよと
だからそれ でもそんなもんでね
そちらはきちんと勉強して
それなりに上手くなったとなったし
私は何も知らなかったんだからやらなかったんだから
まあ下手なまんまで止まったしね
ですから それぐらいでカルマはわかるんです
自分の行為によってふさわしい結果が得られているんだと
正しい結果 それはもう先にもっと膨張しちゃうと
まあ来世もそうなるだろうと
過去生でもそうなっただろうと理解することはできるんですね
例えば人間の世界を見ると
我々みんなもう性格バラバラなんですね
性格ぴったし二人いないんですね
同じ家族の兄弟はもう顔も形も全部違うんです
同じ両親の子供なのに
似ているところはいくらかあるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり違うでしょうし
それで子供たちに嫌 なんて言いますか
一番嫌なことを言いたければ
両親に言える言葉あるんです
比べてあげること ものすごく子供たち
それ嫌なんですね お兄ちゃんだったらよく勉強しますよと
もし小さい子供たちがいるんだったら言ってみてください
あれほど嫌なことはないんです
あるいはまあ 上の子に妹のこと見てください
しっかり勉強してちゃんとやってるんではないかと
あなたなんですか？と
兄弟を比べるってならば
もうたまにあんまり頭の良くないお母さんたち
すぐ比べちゃう お父さんたちもそういう風に比べて言ったりするんですね
本人がいい気持ちで言ってるんだけどね
子供のこと考えて あなたもお姉ちゃんのように真面目に頑張れば本当にありがたいのにってことで言ってるんだけど
あれ大失敗なんです 比べちゃったら
で なんで子供が比べられるのは嫌でしょうかね
兄弟だから別にどうってことないでしょうし
そうじゃないんです 兄弟じゃないんです
別々の人間なんです お兄ちゃんはお兄ちゃんで
弟は弟で すごいこの自分のアイデンティティというものを持ってるんです
徹底的に それ間違ってでも比べるようになっちゃうと
その兄弟は大きくなっても不幸なんですね
たまにいるでしょ お姉ちゃんはすごく成功して幸福になったんだけど
私だけダメでしたとかね
そういう風に比べたりする
それで大きくなっても
その問題は自分を追いかけてくる
ですから 比べることは良くないんです
あの教える先生たちも
あの生徒たちを比べてはいけないんです
比べないように気をつけて
その人のアイデンティティを認めてあげてから叱責した方がいいんです
会社の中でも同じなんです
そのその人間は徹底した個人なんです
そのその人は徹底したもう違う人間で
自分のアイデンティティあるんです
ですから 自分が全く違う人間だから
自分の仕事をする 仕事をやり方やら
自分の文章書き方やら
自分の漢字の書き方やら
それはあくまでも自分のもの
あなたもあの人と同じように書きなさいというのは全くもう法則違反なんです
大体我々はついそう言いたがっちゃうんですね
会社でも何とか何とかさんのように
もうあなた方もちゃんと成績出しなさいと
あれでストレスたまったり
神経質になったり 仕事をできなくなったりする
すごい精神的に痛みを感じちゃう
それで合論のいいところはそういうところなんです
人は個人であること 自分の行為の結果は自分得ること
他人にはそれは関係ないんだと
そこは覚えておいて この社会でね
自分が部下を叱るときでも
随分気をつけなくちゃいけない
自分の子供たちを躾したりするときでも
我が子という感じではなくて
それは全く別な独立している人間であると
きちんと人権 人権持っている立派な人やという
その尊さ 心 心になければ絶対うまくいかないんです
そこで このカルノ論から我々にそれを教えてくれるんですね
一人一人はちゃんと人権を持ってるんです
そこでその尊さが出てくるんですね
いいこともあるんです
例えば 自分の弟子一人がいて
全く言うことを聞かないんだと
いくら教えたってももう理解しないんだと
もう大失敗だと思ったら
教える側から見ればすごくそれは心に悩んじゃうんですね
で 子供の場合 必ずあるんですね
子供が何か弱気で生まれたんだと
身体障害があるんだと
で なんかね 昔の日本だったらそれすごいんですね
まあそういう障害なんかで生まれたならば
社会でなかなか自由に生きてやれなくなっちゃうし
で 親 両親が自分のことをものすごくそれでもう悩んだりするんです
僕らの場合は子供がいませんだけど
その代わりにもう弟子とかいるんだから
それで あの いいとこっていうのは
たとえ障害で生まれたっても
例えば僕らの場合言うならば
全く頭が咲いてくれさえ咲かない
もうまるっきりバカの弟子であろうとも
まあそんなに悩んだりする必要はないんです
で その人はその人で 私は私でと
それなりに大人として助けてあげればいいんじゃないかと
ですから この個人のプライバシーと人権とアイデンティティっていうのは大事にする文化では
このあまり人差別とかは出てこないと思いますけどね
集団で物事を考えちゃうと
それは危ないんです それ良くない
ですから 日本の文化ではどう考えるかということは
あまり私はあまり気にいたしませんですけど
仏教では集団的に物事を考えるということはあまり求めないんですね
認めないんです 個人ということで言ってるんです
ですから まあ自分の家族の中で
学校 自分の弟子たちの中で
まあどうしようもない
もう何の育ちこともできない人々もいるかもしれませんし
それはまあその人の行為の結果であって
その人にできることをできるようにしてあげればいいんです
そこで自分が悩んだりして
ああだこうだする必要はないんです
例えば 私に他のお坊さんがね
あなたの弟子はすごい頭が悪いんですと言ったら
私は恥ずかしくなる必要ないんです
あんた偉そうなものうるさくいろんなこと喋ってるんだけど
自分の弟子ぐらいちゃんと育てればどうですかと
すごい頭が悪いでしょうと
そしたら私はまあそうですねと言うんです
あいつはすごい頭が悪いんだと
それで終わり だから言う側が私をなんか私に恥かけたいんですね
私はその責任取らないんです
で この間も僕に言ったんですね
もっとしっかりあの 言ったらどうですかと
それはいい 別に私は何も言いませんと
もう大人たちだから 自分でちゃんと物事を考えて判断して行動すればいいんじゃないかと
自分たちでちゃんと判断して行動しなきゃ
別に私は知りませんと
で それは無責任じゃなくて
余計な心配する必要はないと
そうすると すごくものすごく楽に生きていられるんです
お母さんたちを怒らせるためにはすごい簡単な言葉あるでしょうに
子供にはちょっと子供のことを言ってみてください
すぐ怒るでしょう 学校なんかではね
例えば子供二人が喧嘩しちゃったら
どちらかもう悪い子がいたならば
先生がこのあなたの息子はすごい立場が悪いんですよと言ったら
お母さんがすぐ先生に怒るんで
あんたそれで教師ですかだこだとか
私の子に限っては絶対そんなことやりませんとかね
なんであんなに怒るんでしょうか
あんなバカなこと言って
もうすごい美しい服を着て
お化粧までして言うことだけはもう恥ずかしくてたまらないほどのこと言っちゃうでしょうね
絶対私の子はそんなことやりませんとかね
言っちゃうでしょうね
あれで苦しいんです ですから
たとえ自分の子であろうとも
学校で人をいじめる可能性あるし
それからなんて言いますか
もう外どこか出かけたら万引きする可能性あるし
隠れてタバコを吸う可能性あるし
それは先生に言われたんだからって
私の子はそんなこと絶対やりませんよって目を閉じちゃったら
もうそれで子供育てられませんし
自分も苦しいし 先生とも喧嘩になって学校の関係悪くなっちゃうし
ですから まあああそうですかと
だから なんていうのは
その場合はあまり自分のものをどうせ受け止める必要ない
お母さんが何か自分が悪いように言われたように思っちゃうんです
子供は私のもの 子供が悪いと言ったら私が悪いと言ったんじゃないかと
そう言ってないんです
子供が悪いと言ってるだけなんです
ですから まあ私は自分の例で言うんだけど
他の同じ年の坊さんたちが私に弟子たちはなかなか言うことを聞かなくて
もう遊んでるばっかりではないかと言われたら
ああ そうですね みんなも勉強もしないしね
頭も悪いし 僕の答えはそれだけ
その人はそれから何も言いませんだから
で 僕は逆に逆に言ったんですね
私のことはあまりにも怖いだから私とはあまり喋りませんだからあなた方と仲がいいでしょうね
ですから あんた方は何か言ったらどうですかと
悪いことすると 私と喋るのを怖がっていること知ってるでしょうと
ですから あんた方もそれ何か言ったらどうですかと
逆に言っちゃうんです
その場合は ですから 大体我々にこの人は個人であることはよく理解すると
その自分に関係ある人でも
何か悪いことをしたんだからといって
自分が惨めになることはないんです
ですから 東大出たもうサラリーマンのね
すごい管理職の人が自分の息子を殺す必要ないんです
息子はダメだと 自分が東大出てすごい管理職の仕事
そういうケースあったんだから言いますけどね
それは別に それはお父さんで
息子は勉強嫌いであちこち他のことをね
まあ他の仕事をやりたければ
まあそれはどうぞということにしなくちゃいけないんです
また何か昔 この何か将棋の大変有名な人の場合
なんか子供 なんか問題あったっていう
ちょっと前の話なんですけどね
あれあんまりなんですね
お父さんが将棋のプロかもしれません
だからって子供もそういうふうになる必要ないでしょうに
だからこのカンマッスカタサッマンディティないんだから他人をいじめちゃうんです
子供をいじめる 社会の人々
社会 会社の人々をいじめると
やっぱりこの個人の人権ですか
それはものすごい深いもので
絶対的なもので 全然もう何も言うことはできない
で お釈迦様の教えもそういう教えなんです
例えば あの何々するなかれとか
そうそうしなさいとかね
命令系ないんですね あの神の言葉みたいに
私はなんじらを作ったと
なんじらにはこういうこういう項目を言いますから
これから守りたまえとかね
いうふうな この厳しい命令系はないんです
お釈迦様いうのは悪いことをしない方がいい
悪いことをしたら不幸になるのはあなたですよと
やるかやらないか人の勝手
どこにも命令系はないんです
で まあもう日本訳ございますから
いろいろお釈迦様の言葉をね
見てください ただ提案するだけ
いろんな 例えばこのね
仏教で怒るなと言ってるんですね
で 怒るなと怒るなかれと言わないんです
怒りを持ってる人は自分を破壊するんだと
故に怒りを収めた方が幸福ですよと言うんです
それだけ 怒るか怒らないかどうぞ自由にと
怒ったらあなたは自己破壊するんだと
怒らなかったらあんたは幸福を掴まりますよ
それだけのこと ですから
人に怒るな怒るなと言ったっても
すぐつい怒りが生まれるんだから
威張るな威張るなと言ったっても
威張る人はすぐ威張ってしまっちゃいますから
ですから 言い方は威張ってはいけませんよ
威張ったらあんたはみんなに嫌われてひどい目に遭いますよと
それだけ 私は知りませんと
私の責任じゃないんだと
一応言っておきましたと
[背景音楽]お釈迦様教えは全部そういう感じなんで
一応言っておきますけど
それで人が例えば何も知らなくて
私はどうすればいいんですか？それだったらあなたはこういうこういう風にすればどうですかと
しなさいと言わないんです
あるバラモン人が お釈迦様はずっと人間の幸福のことばっかりお話ししていたんだからね
あんたはものすごく人間はどうすれば幸福になるかどうか
人間はそういう人間の幸福のことをよく知ってますけど
よく喋ってますけどね
人間が堕落する方法を知ってますかと
知ってますよ 聞きたいんですか？と聞きたいんだと
で教えたんです 女遊びしなさいと
夜遅くまで賭け事やりなさいと
もう思い存分酒飲んで
それにおごりなさいと
どんな人にも嘘言いなさいと
人を騙しなさいと とことん思い存分怠けてみなさいと
仕事をちゃんとしないで
朝早く起きないで まあ寝たい放題寝て
食べたい放題って言って
もう怠けてみなさいと
それも言ったんですね
で ということは まあそれを知っているんです
別に それは別にやったら人は不幸になる
だからお釈迦様はなんでそんなことを言うかというのは
質問したんだからおっしゃったんだけど
そんなことをやるかやらないかということは人の自由
そこでその人はあまりもおかしいんだからね
まあお釈迦様が聞いたんですね
あんた何の仕事をやってるんですかと
聞いたらもう賭け事をして
それでいくらか儲けて食べてるんですね
賭け事っていうのは必ず儲からないものなんです
悪いことをしないと あれなんています？いろいろこのカードの場合でも
上手な人はよく知ってるんで
それごまかす方が ダイスしたっても
上手な人がちゃんとこの自分好きなポイント出るように出すことできるんですね
ですから このそういう悪いことを勉強して
それで人のお金あの不正的に取って生活していてね
ですから そういう仕事ですかと
そしたらそれにお釈迦様は一つ言いましたけどね
あんたはまあ人を騙して
騙したお金でね 家族を養って
子供にご飯食べさせて
まあそれで幸福だと思ってますかと
人を騙す人はもう完全に自分も騙されてしまいますよと
というふうにしっかり言ったそうですけどね
ですから このお釈迦様に人が堕落する方法を教えてくださいと言ったら教えてあげる
人は幸福になる方法を教えてくださいと言ったら教えてあげる
やるかやらないか人の自由で
それもこのカマサカタサッマディッティカは言ってるんですね
行為は自分のものであって
人は完全に独立して 何て言いますか
個人であって その行為の自由
判断の自由っていうのは法則として認めているんです
それは真理なんです 誰かに我々は操られているわけじゃないんです
例えば 日本の法律に我々は束縛
縛られているのではないかと
全然法律守るか守らないかというのは国民の自由なんです
縛られているわけじゃないんです
でも法律破ったら不幸になる
法律を守ったら平和で生きていられる
それも事実なんです どっちかにするかと自分で決めればいいんです
それで法律も破って その上幸福になりたいというのは
あまりにももうね 考えすぎなんですね
そういう風にこの世の中で我々は誰かに支配されてない
我々は自由であると 自由であることはあるんだけど
行為には結果がある それはもう宇宙の法則でどうしようもないんだと
だから我々は行為を選べばいいんです
私は選ぶと 法律を守るか法律を犯すかっていうのは
私が選んでやればいいんです
人のお金盗んでご飯食べるか
仕事をしてお金もらってご飯食べるかと私が決めればいいんです
でも悪い行為に悪い結果といい行為にいい結果っていうのはまた宇宙法則で決まってるんです
人のお金を盗んでご飯食べちゃったら
私はそこでまあ捕まるし
仕事をしてご飯食べると誰も捕まることはなく
すごい堂々たる姿でご飯食べられるし
幸福になれるし そういうことで
仏教の合論というのは自由論であって
人間は自由であることは認めている教えなんです
自由でありながら 我々は宇宙の法則の中にいるんだと
この宇宙の法則はどのように我々は扱った方がいいかということは
これからの講演でできるだけ詳しく説明したいとは思ってます
するかしないかわかりませんだけど
それから この一つのポイントだけ言って
今日の話は終了いたします
もう一つ ポイント一つ
で あの益共という言葉なんですね
だから私は今 徹底的に人間自由と言ったでしょうに
徹底的に人間だけじゃないんです
動物もそうなんです すべての生命はみんな個人なんです
自分で判断できる 自分で判断する
自己責任 例えばこのグループが悪いグループが来て
私を脅かして何か悪いことをしなさいと言ったんだから
私はやったんだと 言っても自分がやったんだから
例えばこの子供たちの中で見られる現象でしょうね
この悪いグループに入っちゃったら
もう悪いグループにもいじめられるんだから
もう怖くてもう万引きをしたんだと
でも結局万引きしたのは自分なんです
だから小さい時からもう自己責任であることをすべてが教えた方が強い人間になるんです
特に今 日本の社会にある
このみんなと合わせて行動しましょうということの反対なんですけど
合わせる必要ないんです
自己責任でやればいいんです
誰でも幸福になりたいでしょうね
当たり前でしょうし それだったら自分の責任自分で取りなさいと
たとえ 20人の人々が来て
これやりなさい やらなかったらもうひどい目に遭わせますよと言ったっても
自己責任ある人やらないんです
その時はその人は強いんです
だからもうやらせることもできないんです
あのあることわざありますね
馬をね 水場ですか そこに引っ張るのは一人にもできますと
一人人間でも馬を引っ張ってくることできますけど
水を飲ませることは 100人が集めたってもできないんだと
[背景音楽
]One person can fool the horse but hundred people cannot make the horse
drink water.飲むのは馬の責任なんです
ですからこの で まあ皆様にも私にも若い時
学生の時がありましたし
大体学校で勉強している時のみんな
みんな善人でしたという
それはそうじゃないでしょうに
勉強できる人 できない人
悪いことをする人 する人しない人にいたんですね
で 私は学校で勉強した時も
私はすごい体が小さかったし
かなり体でっかいすごい僕より 2倍ぐらい体大きいもいたんです
何人かが それまた悪いことをするわ
もう喧嘩するわ 人をぶん殴るわと
でも私は小さい時からもう徹底的に自己責任ということを教え込まれていたんだから
自分でも決めて 私はやらない
やったら私はひどい目に遭うんだと
先生に叱るのは私ですよと
それで一人も私にこれやりなさい
やりなさいと言わないんです
やらないんだと 頑固とやりませんよと言ったら
向こうが怖くなっちゃうんです
なぜならばそうすると暴力
暴力でいろんなひどいことをしてやらせなくちゃいけないでしょ
そこまでやっちゃったら向こうは完全に捕まりますからね
人間のこの弱さね 捨てた方がいいんです
このカマッサカタサンマディッティを作って
自分が決してひどい目に遭う必要ないんです
自分が決して不幸になる必要ないんです
人に言われたんだからああだこうだとか
そんなことやったら私がもう悪いことやったことになります
やりませんと あんた方は勝手にやりなさいと
じゃあやらなかったら仲間に入れてあげませんと
結構ですよと あんた方みたいな仲間に入らなくたって
一人でいいんだと じゃああなたに友達が一人もいないんですよと
いいですと これで友達を作るために何で悪いことする必要あるんですか
あの強さ必要なんですね
そのこの強さも この合論で我々に教えてくれるんです
強くなれと 自分が悪いことしちゃったら
もうどこかでハメられるんだから
ですから このこれは何とか号でしょうと言って
なんか弱くて弱気になる教えじゃないんです
すごい科学的に徹底的に言ってる
ものすごい強気の教えなんです
ですから このこの正見
ある人はすごい強い 自信満々
友達が一人もいなくたっても
だから何ですかとという感じでいられるんです
友達がどうしても必要というならば
いい友達が選ぶと せっかく選んだ友達が自分に悪いことをしようというならば
まあどうそうと関係なく
もう友達関係切ると なぜならば
自分が自分 自分で生まれてきたのに
自分で生まれて自分で生きて
自分で死んでいかなくちゃいけないんだから
友達であろうか 両親であろうかなんもやってくれませんだからね
勉強も同じことなんです
親が言うんだから勉強するのはよくないんです
ですから その我々子供を躾ける時でも
小さい時からもこの自己責任を教えてあげちゃうと
例えば子供がもういい加減に走ったところで机に頭がぶつかったと
そこでニャーニャーと泣くでしょうに
お母さんがすぐああ痛いの痛いの飛んでいけとか
冗談じゃないんで そんなことは
自分で走ってぶつかったんだから自分で我慢しろと
それだけのことでしょうに
であまりにも泣くと もうなんで泣くの？僕はいつも子供にそう聞くんで
なんで泣くの？何かあったの？みたいな
そしたらこちらぶつかったんだと
ああそう痛い うん なんでぶつかったの？それで
なんでそっちぶつかったの？私だったらぶつかってないのに
で 何のことなく自己責任
そこで頭に入っちゃうんですね
自己責任が頭に入ったならば
私は子供の面倒を見てあげるんです
それ それ前にはやらない
血が出ていたっても お寺
自分のお寺でも結構子供たち集まりますから
やっぱりいろいろトラブル起こしたり
何かを打ちて怪我したり
いろいろありますけど
もうちゃんと責任持って面倒は見るんだけど
まず自己責任 で 認めたから
自分がこうやって走ってきたんだからと言ったら
ああそう じゃあちょっと見せてごらんと
それそこから見せてもらって
あ これは大したことないとか
なんとかもうちょっとあるんだったらそれなりになんとかすると
で 普通は人間そうじゃないんです
すぐ感情的になって ああだこうだとかね
ですから この自分のお寺で
この子供たちの面倒を見る先生たちは別にいるんだけど
私がいると彼らが一日中かかる問題っていうのは
私は １分以内で解決するんですね
泣く子はすぐ泣く 泣きやめてもらう
何の問題もない ものすごい喧嘩している二人が瞬時に仲良くしてあげちゃうとかね
みんなそれ勉強したいんだけど
顔をあきれて見てるんですね
どういうやり方ですかと
このやり方っていうのは
それはこういうやり方なんです
鋭い知恵ときちんとした論理的に
科学的にものを見ればいいんです
感情は置いといて 感情の代わりに愛情ですか
もう誰でも幸福でいてほしいと
誰でも平等であって みんなそれぞれ個人ですよと
悪いことをする子供に私が聞くのは
まあそんなことやってあんた偉いと思ってるのと
偉くなりたくそうやってるんだからね
大体それぐらいの言葉で
子供の心にじっと言ってることは入って入っちゃうんです
ですから この自己責任
そこも大事なこと 大事なことであって
で それからそれと関係なく
このそれはそうなんですけど
この周りの影響のこと
悪い仲間に入ったとかね
その時はどうなるかと
本当に悪い仲間に入ったら確実に自分が悪くなるんです
なぜならばどこかに弱みがあるんですね
悪い仲間に入ったこと
どうか仲間欲しいんだと
寂しいんだと それで入った仲間が悪かったと
そうするとすぐその人々の影響を受けちゃう
なぜならば 自分が仲間が欲しいという自分の弱みがあったんだから
で 私は強くなるよと言ったっても
人間はね まあそんな簡単に強くならないかもしれませんだけど
ですから 我々は弱いと思うならば
かなり気をつけなくちゃ
人間 我々はこの他人の影響で不幸になることがあるんです
他人の影響で それは影響であって
やったのは自分なんです
悪い仲間に入ったら もう悪いことばっかり言われるんだから
それは正しいと誤解しちゃってやってしまったのは自分だから
ですから 弱い人はそういう悪い影響を避けた方がいいんです
そこでもう一つ 我々の運命が決める要素があるんです
この宇宙の法則というか
この地球の法則 例えばインフルエンザがインフルエンザが流行ると
インフルエンザにかかっちゃうでしょうに
香港ウイルスとかいろいろね
新しい 新型のインフルエンザが毎年出ますでしょうし
そういう風にインフルエンザにかかっちゃったら
それ自分が不幸でしょうに
あのH1Go7にかかって亡くなった人もいるでしょうに
じゃあそれはどんなカルマですかと
どんな業ですかと ウイルス入ったのは誰のせいではないかと
それはどうでしょうかと
その時も考えてください
弱いんだからインフルエンザ入っちゃうでしょ
どこか自分が気が抜いちゃったんだから
気をつけたら 強かったら
その影響は入らないはずなんですね
でも いくら気をつけたっても
そこらで気をつけられないこともあります
子供たちはそれをH1Go7入ってるかないかわからないでしょうに
ですから そういう風に我々はまあいくら頑張ってもやられる時もあります H1Go7
にやられた子供たちと同じく
で まあそれはまあ まあどうしようもないんですね
ですから そこら辺では別にそんなに真剣に考える必要ないんです
まあインフルエンザにかかったよと
体が弱かったんだからと
それなりになんとかすればいいんです
それから体の状態もありますね
自分の体の状態 で 生まれつき自分が一応弱いね
ウイルスやらそういうものに弱い体を持って生まれてならば
アトピーを持って生まれたならば
まあまたお手上げ状態でしょう
で そういうことはいくらかカルマ論からちょっと外しておいた方がいいんです
そこで理解して 自分がアトピー性ですよと理解して
ちゃんとそれなりに自分を管理すればよろしいんですね
いくら自由だ自由だと言ったっても
そこら辺では自由はない
でも その時に見えるのは弱いということなんですね
アトピーがあるということも弱いということだから
普通に言えばその人は弱い
だからもう 影響を受けてしまうちゃう
そこで気をつけることで十分なんですね
この星占いとか人相占いとか
世界出てくるのはそこら辺からなんですね
我々は特別な人間と言ったっても
まあ宇宙のほんのわずかな一部だから
確実に宇宙の星やら惑星やらもう太陽やらなんだかんだでもそちらの変化は体に響くんです
それは避けられない どうしても
で そこで体のいろんな変化とかね
起こるんです そこはどうしようもないんだから
まあ忘れた方がいいんです
だから仏教では占いはないんです
例えば 金星はこの位置にいればこういうこういう運命だよと言うでしょ
それ聞いてどうなるの？金星こっちじゃなくてこっち行ってちょうだいと
移動できますか？できませんだから
だからこの星占いは聞いたってもろくなことじゃないし
自分知ってることしか言ってくれないし
効かないんだからといってどうったことないんです
で 手相占いあるでしょ
手相占いでやら人相占いで見るのはこの体の構造なんですね
体の構造は心の回転によって変化するんです
ですから いくらか体を見て言えるんです
占いは 大体まあ五十パーセントぐらい当たるようには言えるんです
だからって何のことないんです
なぜならば 聞いてみてください
手相占い 言ってることは全部自分が知ってることなんです
まるっきり知らなかったことは言わないんです
知ってることを聞いてもらうために手相占いのところにお母さんに聞けば
自分忘れたところまで言ってくれるでしょうに
ですから まあ別に嘘と言ってるわけじゃなくて
まあ我々のこの心の回転によって体の形が変わる
それはみんな知ってること
不思議じゃないんですね
悩んじゃうと顔色どうですか？顔色悪くなるでしょうね
悩み事あればあるほど
それでどんどんそれ時間経つと
その顔になって決まってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 楽しいこと終わっちゃうと
すぐ心が明るくなっちゃうでしょうね
それで体が明るくなっちゃうでしょうね
それは時間過ごすと なんとなく体の調子が良くなってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから それは心の回転が体に影響を与える
それをわかってない人々は
売れないとそれ言ってくれる
人相いらない 手相売らないと
星売らないとか それ聞いたっても
まあ例えば手に手にこういう線を見て言うでしょ
手相占いは ああ これ何か悪いこと聞かれた
あなた ちょっと寿命は短いんだと
あれ カミソリででも線を伸ばしてもらいますかね
何もできませんからね
ですから 仏教ではそういうのはには頼るなと
聞いても聞かなくても別にどうったことはないんです
寿命は短いという人が
もういくら頑張っても短いことは短いんです
それは伸びないんです
ですから このだいたいこの宇宙の法則と心と体の関係から出てくるいろんな現象を見て
このみんな占い世界は出ているんです
そこも我々は普通の仏教の口論でなくてもいいと
どうしても聞きたければ聞いたってもいいし
例えばどうしても結婚相手が見つからないんだと
そこでもう顔を見たらすぐ分かりますけど
なぜかということはね
まあ私だったら手は見ませんだけど
まあすぐ分かります 原因がね
それは直接言えないでしょ
大体私にも言えないし
占い師にも言えないんですね
こういうわけでっていうことは
その代わりにやっぱり男の運というんだよ
その場合は 男運が少ないんですねとかね
あんたはまあまあ独身で頑張った方がいいんではないかと言ってくるだけのことで
本当のこと言えませんだからね
それで結婚相手見つからない人は占ってもらったと
占い師がやっぱり結婚できないと言ってくれたんだと
だから別にどうなるんですか
それだけのこと 結婚相手見つからない人は
占ってもらっても見つからないし
まあ占ってもらなくても見つからないし
だから必要なのは だから今も占いなんで流行ってるかというと
そういう占いというよりはカウンセリングしてあげるんですね
だからみんな行くんだよ
カウンセリングの部分はいいんです
で その人々はなんとなく感じでわかって
あなたはね こういうこういうふうにして
こういうこういうふうにすれば
こうこういうふうなやつはもうもう後で
まあ 1年  2年でまあこうなりますよと言ってくれる
それで自信がついてきて
まあぴったし占ってくれたんだからといって
自分が明るい方向へ行動する
そうするといい結果が出てくるかもしれません
ですから 占いというよりは大事なのはカウンセリングなんですね
明るくしようとしっかり頑張りましょうという教えなんですね
で とにかく我々は宇宙のほんのわずかな塵一つも当たらない小さなものだから
あの 物質的にはかなり影響受けてるんですね
それは否定できない で
大気が汚染したら全ての地球の生命がそれなりに変化しちゃうんです
そういうのはもうお手上げしか何も言えませんね
その場合 それも我々の行為の結果なんですけど
で もし火山なんか爆発して全部いきなり大気の状態が悪くなったら
そういうのは業に入りませんね
そういうのはあくまでも自然法則
でもそれだったら人類みんなそれなりの何とか結果にはなるんです
でも原子爆弾を起こしちゃって
もうかなり人類が破滅しちゃったら
それは人間やったことで
それはコントロールできるし
ですから 最後に言いたがっているのは
我々は個人であって独立して自由なんですが
その中にこの宇宙の法則と人間関係の人間の影響とかいう影響はあるということ
そこら辺では諦めるしか方法ないんです
そういうのはコントロールできませんから
で 時間なくなりましたので
まあ一応ここら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました